clark county gearing up for cannabis
consumption lounges as joe moeller
reports commissioners went over what it
would take for lounges to open in the
county
lounges are legal but the rules and
regulations are still being finalized
today clark county commissioners went
over the drafted regulations that are on
the table right now this location has
been here a year canastar's in downtown
las vegas is a dispensary we're looking
forward to the lounges because the
tourists come in and they have nowhere
to smoke brenda gonzalez says they want
to put a lounge behind the building here
when and if they can it's going to be a
big plus for our industry she's like
many others in the industry waiting for
the green light to move forward as the
state works on the laws tuesday county
commissioners went over the drafted
regulations that are on the table for
lounges right now a temporary license is
issued if everything is in order from
zoning to licensing they discuss what
will need to happen on the county level
so we just take the application or would
they all come before us commissioners
raised concerns and brought up questions
to both licensing and zoning departments
i think that the board has to determine
whether this is going to be a land use
approval whether it's going to go before
the board and that sort of thing and
what the parameters will be industry
experts even weighed in aisha goings is
from the state cannabis equity and
inclusion committee she says when it
comes to the licenses set aside for the
social equity applicants she believes
they should be for nevada residents if
there is a possibility that the county
could put must be a nevada resident as a
cap that would work in the benefit of
those nevadans who have specifically
been
disenfranchised by past cannabis
policies the questions and concerns will
move on to the nevada cannabis
compliance board's next meeting
meanwhile people in the industry are
getting eager i feel like it's very
beneficial for the economy and the
industry as a whole a number of cannabis
compliance board workshops have already
taken place for these rules and
regulations the next one is set to
happen next friday april 29th after that
they will vote on these rules and then
they will be finalized reporting in
downtown las vegas joe mohler live local
now thanks joe the cannabis compliance
board has said they expect the first
lounge to be operating by late summer or
autumn